Gaming which I am a terraria veteran and
due to popular request I will play this
game those were all lives by the way
hold up let me customize my guy there
are some funky haircuts in this game
holy cow this one pp sets out into
poopoo FTC please let me be alright I
just want to play games here we go yeah
stab him get his knees then this is
pretty look at that
Hey look new game the world exciting
yeah I have basically no knowledge of
terraria just a weak layer here ok I'm
not a veteran but I do know minecraft
and I know shopping dying trees it's the
way to go
hey did it by guys impressed look at him
he loves it
if he's not impressed by my shopping
skills chop chop chop he should be at
least impressed by my haircut oh dude he
kills people awesome okay we got slime
stamp stamp
hey alright I'm good at game I'll take
it
I like the background that we got we're
in some sort of forest crazy mister bees
please look away okay I will replant
these streets I think you can with the
acorns
I like how you get an at least an axe to
begin where the Minecraft be like hence
just use your hands okay so now what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna clear out this
area a little bit since I am a terraria
veteran I know how to play game damn
that guy's slain dude
terraria boyfriend confirmed sorry
Marcia okay alright can you have a
terraria girlfriend actually there's so
many questions I have about this game
can you freakin terraria because you
can't freakin minecraft and I think that
at least is one of the great tragedies
of our modern society alright should I
be quiet yes okay sorry
okay tonight it's lime kill
it's how we do it in the hood okay so
now what we will do is happy I'm what
how do I build stuff oh here we go I can
make a workbench okay I made to work
benches for no reason
there you go place it done stop squirrel
get I must say get him oh my god I'm so
sorry I didn't think you would do
anything I'm a monster
don't look at me well his name Connor
Connor please he can't even talk to me
these frickin slimes are everywhere go
away okay so next to my workbench now we
can build share we can build wall yeah
yeah yeah yeah whoa
well many one this is how we will build
our house yeah yeah look at this house
look at this dude you see this house no
no no too big actually dammit okay fine
I did realize I don't want to build a
house I'm gonna build the IKEA Tower
this will be the tallest structure this
world has ever seen
yes yes I'm out of wood you kidding me
okay I still have wood so I can now make
a wall right I make wall
yeah okay
I build house it's whatever this is
actually how real life starts as a
Swedish person this game is very similar
build house from would lack boughs okay
and I know terraria veterans are
watching this and they think they're so
epic but listen let's say this is how
pros do it okay I want to make door door
one two and torch okay
can you build a meatball in Terraria
other dogs named Sven in throw how do I
get that stuff okay Bri guys I just have
a lot of random questions for no reason
at all okay now we can place the door
slime you better not get in my house I
swear to you oh my god I will murder you
you know what happened to that squirrel
place the door
place it yes I did a thing I like the
soundtrack it's good it's funky okay oh
look we have a little friend in our
house that's so cute
can't enter poor don't allow poor people
in my house
those are the rules it's the same as
real life okay now we have cute house
get off my property
oh my god this game is wrong I'm never
going outside again the world is awful
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'll I won't do that
again I swear I think I think I'll never
do that again
okay we can build the table that's cool
I think I want floor
yeah let's redo all this I want hardwood
floor you know why that's right kids cuz
I'm not poor poor I killed all that
support you're poor this is the worst
running joke Connor I'm sorry you can't
sleep with me hey can you make bed soon
manga terraria how do I knock this down
poor I won't do that again I swear okay
before it gets dark I should probably
get some stone and stuff right there it
is Cod there's somebody slime gasps my
whole my whole no one can touch oh god
is dark okay so I got a place torches
yeah Oh God slightly bunny you can't go
to my house what is happening over there
bunny Oh Carly's bunny gonna die
[Music]
okay Joe yeah took everything from me
okay this is my house I'm safe epic I am
NOT happy but I do have my workbench
what can i craft a wooden hat cool I got
a hat now no my beautiful hair is gone
come on so many hair options in this
game and I can't even show it up
technically I don't need pants but
whatever sorry Connor you can't sleep
with me
alright let's decorate we got a chair
chairs are good
I like chairs oh god please let the
bunny in bunny please hurry bunny please
bunny son go go go
ARCA go there's gonna be zombies out
there bunny I need to protect please
you're my only friend in this dark world
that's right my sweet child keep going I
love you
come on yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah one
more one more come on go come on get in
oh he jumped over bunny I swear to God
trust me on this one oh god what is that
Bunny's gone by repeat bonnie is gone I
loved him like a child
cool this is fine I'm not going out
no don't care there's a giant floating
eyeball I think I'm good I'll dig a hole
here in my floor I think I saw some
expensive stuff there this yeah lead
nice just don't drink it it was a joke
well with us a freaking star what oh my
god what do you stay I need to get that
star here we go Oh God
okay I get to start Oh God yes I got it
falling sorry Oh God I think not should
probably cover up the floor again
property get off it that's what I
thought
damn I'm slaying dude don't think so
nice dude I'm good at this game it's
almost like I am a veteran even though I
am NOT a veteran you know I'm saying
span hello a mine all day a mine all
night mine are the diamonds in Terraria
question work another fallen star are
they rare or not probably nothing
damn I wonder how far down I can dig
I've been digging forever god I played
like 10 minutes I'm already obsessing
about unnecessary details I already know
this game is gonna do bad things to me
brah I'm making cute ice tears for no
reason get on my level
I swear that bird is saying bhaga bhaga
bhaga okay I need some more wood Connor
my boyfriend my minecraft boyfriend
what's up damn Connor you're rich you oh
you want what say oh my god yes a bunny
my sweet chat no dang it oh sorry sorry
oh well I won't do that again I swear so
anyway now we can craft a hammer
yes what's that I think with a hammer
you can take out the walls that I made
yeah oh my god Jesus Lord
stop wires slime so evil what the hell
is that
oh my god it's super strong Connor do
something this is going to be the most
glorious tower I'm telling you guys oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah almost died but no
pain no gain
come on gamers hey by the way Sarah
that's so far that's pretty good what is
this - so what's a platformer I can jump
on them that's nice okay it might be
extremely ugly it might not have a roof
but it's mine craft alright let's head
out any more wood I know I need like 10
and stuff so I can make better equipment
but we'll get there gamers will get
there okay let's head out maybe there's
stuff that I haven't seen that we need
to explore Hey look thing perfect let's
get that rich I'm rich
Thank You tin yeah yeah perfect all of
it you so dumb you mining BAM is with
the stone pickaxe okay here's a scorpion
what what just happened you can what
nope oh that's right I'm the man yeah
what is that yeah hey I come from
foreign lands
hello how are you I will no I mean no
harm
die die die all of you dead next one
dead thank you hello cactus tree hello
desert tree Oh doesn't drop any wood so
there are different biomes I never seen
this it's so weird
Oh what look at this drop dude nice man
I ain't doing that
Oh blue slime hey Dora hey though I'm
good Jesus it's fast
No
what are you kidding me what the hell is
that thing
what'd I lose did I lose my stuff that's
my cave no story okay it's your house I
changed my mind it's your house you can
live in it now don't even care
oh god I want to get my stuff I was so
closed was night there I am okay now we
just have to deal with the giant ant
lion oh god it's getting dark
it's fine it's fine this happens to
everyone in their life at some point
where I ant lion takes over your house
you're literally you're so useless but
you still have to die okay he left
there's not much to stay for it to be
honest I think I should build a roof
that's just a theory I have so I'm gonna
stay true to that theory and do it the
tower of Ikea
I don't know how tall you can build in
this game but I'm telling you right now
it's gonna be frickin dippin nipple
licking tall dude okay that's just all
as we're making it for now listen I
don't need your criticism I just started
playing maybe I should put some torches
outside right there you go maybe put
some there yeah this was better actually
I like that Conor you psychopath there
you go
Tower of Ikea will grow stronger just
wait
look at that staircase though so
apparently this game has an ending now
or at least with the new update so I
figured it's a good time to actually
finally play it I it's one of those
games that people keep talking about
people keep saying how great this game
is and I and when they tell me about it
I'm like yeah I can see myself like in
May I just know there's a lot to learn
and I am NOT a veteran and I keep lying
excuse me excuse me sorry what is that
can i pause hello stop stop just keep
digging
if you don't look back it will not see
your fine Felix you're absolutely fine
you're you're absolutely fine just stone
just don't look at it just dig backwards
that's right
why is that they're wiser just dig is
king
I'm gonna keep digging that mean just
keep mining and your problems will go
away Felix that's how real life work
come on hey we got some tin there nice
yeah baby oh yeah
I feel like an obligation to fill all
this in because it looks so ugly I'm
sorry okay we connect it to a cave here
I think whoa whoa what is this
what is this turning Stan it's that a
Swedish word because that translates to
heavy stone in Swedish that is I've
always liked wait what'd you say that in
English
whoa look at this waterfalls so
beautiful my god I'm terrified what is
this lead don't drink it don't drink it
gamers someone comes up to you and say
hey you want to drink some lead just say
now pretty pie told me now all right
we're finding a lot of good stuff I like
it I like it how do I know if it's Oh
God
how do I know if it's daytime or not oh
my god that is so annoying can't come to
my house Swedish people only sorry they
want to enter my beautiful so now what
oh heck the sword what that's so cool is
that good damn Cactus chair
what were they smoking when they made
this cactus chair yeah just take a seat
down there and the cactus chair it's
quite comfortable yes yes cactus chair
so good there's a but I can't make a
punch
oh is it yo yo yo yos okay what yours
awesome whoa let's try cactus sword
get off my property get off my property
Swedish Show Passport thank you thank
you thank you whoa okay I'm strong now
okay I'm pretty freakin thick and strong
now oh yeah and it's morning gamers good
morning gamers we're building IKEA Tower
to the stars can you enter the moon in
terraria illness in Minecraft I swear
the bird Sabo Gabor Gabor changed my
mind
like in I'm into it look at this house
through the yo-yo though I guess tougher
enemies will come all right now I'm
brave enough to head out and slay some
freaking I do think the yo-yo is better
[Laughter]
take my dog out for a walk just plumbing
through I don't think so
oh god I don't think so mr. slain whoa
that's damage I am strong all right I
can definitely head out let's get some
freakin cactus dude yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I ain't afraid I ain't afraid take
it
taste it taste it taste it taste it
taste it that's what I thought you eat
dirt you get hurt that's how that good
see how do I get this there it is that's
art Reese everyone all right we have
quite the obstacle ahead and what I'm
about to say might blow your mind
there's bridges in Terraria
that's right gamers that's what I'm
freakin talkin about all right if it's
ugly kill it what in the world is that
stop stop you okay this might be a
problem I'm okay he's pretty strong I'm
not gonna lie
oh god he does a lot of damage but I
have yo-yo touch it touch it touch it
touch it I said touch it
Oh God bridges uh-huh okay I don't wanna
die not like this Oh God oh stop yes yes
that's what I find how does it feel to
be sure to short can't relate [ __ ] all
right bridges dumb body once told me
okay eat eat it eat it eat it eat it
maybe I need to kick the sword these
guys yeah I'm not afraid of cactus yes
dude I'm slaying oh god oh god what is
that excuse me excuse me just a moment
sir
I don't like you I'm scared
all right I'm heading back home I'm
scared hmm sucks say yeah yes Jojo what
is you're approaching me in Japanese let
me just sit down on my cactus chair ah
that feels good
cactus table okay I can build a fence
that's kind of cute
what else can I build cactus pickaxe
really you know what comes a time in
every woman's life where he's got to
build a cactus
lantern seriously all right I guess I'll
make a furnace I think I should make one
of this right maybe we'll make furnace
here okay that's pretty good hey Connor
it's not your house
Connor you're not my boyfriend silly
Connor I can place my workbench here and
cactus chair which is very important
here nice
all right so what can I craft with the
this tin bar okay how many six seven and
I can make tomb stain as well
only one lead okay calm down
and what can I do with that I think I
can do stuff with that right web bro oh
nice
damn there's so much stuff you can do
I'm just like uh overwhelmed so maybe
now in the crafting I can make different
stuff right Lee Danville used to craft
items from metal bars okay maybe we'll
place that up here I got it I'm gonna
achieve it now we can make lead fence
ooh
lead the short sword yes give me what
else I can make a bow mine card can I
make a Minecraft in Minecraft
I should again a lead pickaxe use a
diamond diamond diamond with the lead
pickaxe okay I'm into this so can i huh
oh my god yes
no the nest for then broke we got 40
dude this is awesome all the way damn it
can I make a minecart Connor get out of
my house so apparently when you have 50
silver there should be a guy coming to
your house I'm told at least I don't
know statue cactus lamp really I've been
playing so long I don't even care this
is super fun I think I need to a meeting
down be right back on there don't I I
have a sword now I feel pretty good
about it we enjoy yo look at this this
is my dawg
oh and the cactus dude that cactus is
shop shop shopping dude oh god what just
happened
she says this is like a different area
okay so now I can use the rope here I
think except I can't see anything
hopefully you can carry me all the way
nice what is this oh nice more tin
starting to get the hang of this well
the water falls down oh that's cool hey
look at that
I'm so easily impressed by water float
down that's so cool oh god what was that
look there's my pee pee down there okay
a lot of stuff here
nice I don't know what just happened
what is that sand oh my god it's like
minecraft I'm letting the water free
nice tonight just like cover the water
look at this dude I assume the further
down you get the more epicness you get
as well just like women that was a
terrible sex joke I'm so sorry I'm
actually addicted because I'm not saying
anything I'm just playing the game at
this point yeah I want to dig this
tunnel okay I don't care what it takes
I'm gonna dig this tunnel
what just happened down there I think we
should head back up and I'll try and
make better pickaxe and maybe even a
minecart if I can would that be sick
damn it's dark outside hey Connor just
left a bunch of money come in bunny
it'll be safe with me all right
maybe now we can finally make 10 pickaxe
nice Oh bunnies almost in please listen
to me I will protect you
yes you're safe you're with me
don't worry you're my new friend I named
you Ben
because the bunnies Sven yeah sorry no
no your friend cannot come in this is
not a hotel now where was I I can craft
mmm nothing cool what I thought I was
rich
where are the mine carts oh I need wood
I'm completely out of wood I might have
to open up one second man's got a shop
shop you know I'm saying oh this morning
that perfect alright so now we can plant
a couple trees because mr. bees is
probably watching sorry mr. beads here
we go look look look how many trees 20
million right there I'm planting 20
million trees in Terraria
okay that should be okay for now right
oh my god where is Ben where is Ben Oh
Connor let him out didn't he
you're dead Connor you're dead yo yo yo
yo
I build a fence in the trees I'm
building a fence you're not allowed in
here anymore
you're not allowed past my fence see
that you're not allowed don't ever come
near my house again you murderer hate
you
unbelievable how do I build a minecart
I'm gonna put up a sign no corners are
allowed to enter this area if broken I
will be forced to use self-defense say
oh my god we haven't been number two
been number two please please been
number two I'm serious all right we
build the wall so Ben can't a me and
Connor can't come in there you go he's
with me now he's safe
damn it takes a lot of materials to
Vista you think I ta keo tower will be
done by now but now fine wait I can just
click what
but oh yeah that's all I have I have a
little mine car that's so cute all right
how do I dispose that's so cool okay I
thought I had to build what all right
let's keep mining all day gamers I got a
light 10x so epic oh there's so much
faster oh we got a cut one nice so
what's all this sand I think that's a
yes Felix okay sorry
what is that what would stay ill kill it
I see it but I can yes yes got it got it
got it got it
suck it yes we ten whoa whoa whoa whoa
how do I fix that
can I put like dirt underneath a zigzag
from here this suck okay we're through
stairs are my friend my only friend
whoa whoa whoa okay oh God
oh not these oh yeah give me there
that's right
okay time to go back forgot one
[Laughter]
cactus chair hope you die Connor I hope
you die stay behind the wall coward
let's see how are a little trees I've
been growing nice looking good alright
yo your time it's so good I love it
can you just imagine beating the [ __ ]
out of someone with a yo-yo don't think
so
I've got a lot of this morning damn look
at that killing Isis then how's the
sword
ok the sword is really good too I'm just
gonna get a some mush wood as I can how
much silver do I have 68 oh yeah I
haven't made a chest yet I'm so done now
we can put our like crap in there
trapdoor
we're getting there gamers we're getting
there I'm gonna build out a little
balcony that's right and we're gonna
build a little door and then we can go
out on the balcony and say hey Connor
you're not allowed in here
murderer Bam Bam IKEA tower finito for
now damn it
alright gamers I think that's well
enough for one day it's raining
Connor you can stay out there yeah what
does that adorable thing Connor stay
away from it
stay away from me oh god what is this
I'm scared how do I end it how do I
leave save and exit okay for next time
suppose like if you want more of this I
will do more if Ellen DeGeneres give
this show a shout-out I think that could
be really cool and that's it for me for
now see you guys tomorrow bye bye we're
all excited about the new game that's
coming out and I can't wait to play it
it starts with the letter P can you
guess what it is here with E PI pick
ceiling of course what you thought it
was Pokemon dumbass you stinky brainer
you